[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
key
les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais si facile quand on débarque qui
nous attendent rarement assis sur une
chaise un sourire accueillant coin des
lèvres
on croise les doigts pour qu'ils
finissent par faire une connerie et pour
être là le jour béni où ça arrive mais
tous ces meurtres avoués hanté vous vous
envolez j'en veux plus tôt salopards qui
les a commis cet homme ne vit que pour
tuer il connaît toutes les ficelles il
pourra être flic il est incollable en
médecine légale ils procèdent
méthodiquement de façon à laisser aucun
indice derrière lui après avoir choisi
sa victime
elles observent pendant des semaines ils
étudient ses moindres gestes
il sait à quelle heure elle rentre chez
elle à quelle heure ils se couchent elle
seule le matin avant qu'il fasse jour
il peut l'observer d'encore plus près
même si le soleil n'est toujours pas
levé nouvelle journée a déjà commencé
des femmes très pudique à minuit se
promène à moitié nue à 7 heures du matin
et puis finalement ils se décident du
prince ac et fours des outils des
accessoires ruban adhésif menottes armes
attirail complet
il s'introduit chez elle le soir la
fille rentre à la maison
elle a ses habitudes elle ne remarque
rien
[Applaudissements]
c'est super ça
[Musique]
on va danser
non ne fait pas tant de manières
on va bien s'amuser
[Musique]
ch
c'est fait
je t'ai dit
de terre compris
où
[Musique]
quand elle s'évanouit de peur ou de
douleur il l'a ranime encore et encore
je peux savoir ce que vous allez dire
terminée pour aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on
ah ah
tiens
pourquoi tu m'as laissé tourner pour que
tu as autant de mal à accepter
je sais que j'ai fait pour toi tu étais
si près de moi cette nuit là je me
souviens très bien de ce que j'ai
ressenti en entendant le bruit n'était
pas derrière moi la fierté
je croyais que l'événement nous lire et
pour la vie pour moi
c'est ce que nous avons vu de plus beau
je vois encore les flammes
[Applaudissements]
à voir
[Musique]
sauf
on
[Musique]
je
forrester
on doit donner s'insurge en balcon aulas
inspecteurs aunis maquis et bienvenue
sur mon lieu de crime vous cherchez
quelque chose ou bien vous voulez
simplement jeter un coup d'oeil on va
dire gens de chez moi j'habite bien vous
n'avez pas vu les rubans jaunes qui
délimite le périmètre de sécurité
si vous avez fini je le reprends et du
monde sauf si ça pose problème vous
connaissiez cette femme jamais vu qu est
ce qui lui est arrivé elle est morte
c'est ça à aucun moment je ne vous ai
parlé d' homicide
comment se fait-il que vous envoyer
directement cette conclusion avait eu le
chantier la moitié du quartier bouclé
vous avez au moins une douzaine de flics
qui grouillent sur le lieu du crime j'en
sais rien mais je pense pas que ce soit
à cause d'un jeune qui fait péter la
sono bon mais si jamais un détail vous
revenez appelez moi je compte sur vous
[Musique]
allô c'est dur est humble
vous savez on s'est dit de trois mois
hier soir
appartement 350g lui revient à oui on
s'est renseigné surtout en côte puis je
vous être utile
j'entends rien vous êtes occupés liens
de ces bruits on dirait que ça remue pas
mal je peux vous êtes un petit con
bah c'est pas de bol je te là
86 vous voulez peut-être que je rappelle
non vous faites la fille elle est morte
quand elle est morte lundi soir ya trois
jours pourquoi que je sais qui est
l'assassin m'a fait parvenir une photo
où elle était encore vivante c'était
lundi matin pour être exact
[Applaudissements]
as tu balances fait la malle
[Musique]
ok je vais tout avoir fait à temps alors
en poste que vous passiez au bureau ça
vous va ça va c'est une habitude chez
vous parfois ça peut aller jusqu'à deux
semaines
bon apparemment ça répond à la question
qu'on se posait à savoir si les demeures
travers rapport entre eux rien de tel
qu'un bon tueur en série pour donner le
coup d'envoi de la saison il envoie les
photos à domicile lui tranquille le
[ __ ]
il ferait sauter l'audimat dans cette
émission là jeudi sa dernière identité
connue était david alan griffin du
beausset trois ans et demi sur cette
affaire là ça me laisse sans lui
attribuaient déjà on screen dans le même
style à l'époque tu es ce qu'il faut à
chicago je suppose qu'il est venu ici
pour étrangler les jeunes femmes avec un
fil d'acier et victimes ont toujours été
retrouvé à moitié déshabillées mais les
prélèvements n'ont jamais rien donné
même ici il les touche pas c'est pas un
acharné du sexe vous l'avez déjà vu ce
type n'ont personne n'a jamais dit dans
ce cas rien ne permet d'affirmer que
nous avons un phénomène d'argent et quoi
encore qu'est ce que vous faites de ces
photos il a tué une fille dans mon
immeuble ça vous suffit pas
[Musique]
désolé il faut passer rien vous étiez
durable sur l'emballage il est écrit
extérieur ensoleillé mais qu'est ce que
ça donne sous les néons
je regrette alors la faute des
magistrats pas ici moi c'est tout vous
développez les photos sur place oui
je veux bien sûr
est ce que vous faites je le teste avant
de l'acheter
je vais prendre quelques photos
et
vous développerez la pellicule pour moi
[Musique]
magnifique
ouais le chef de la police de chicago
nous a contactés comme on pouvait s'y
attendre le brave on nous invite à
entrer dans la danse
nous allons créer une unité spéciale je
voudrais savoir si vous vous sentez en
état de la diriger je sais qu'à los
angeles los angeles n'a rien à voir ce
n'est plus du tout mon boulot je vais
vous dire si j'ai des séances ont guidé
votre espèce entrer dans ce bureau c'est
juste parce que vous avez trois en
avance sur nos ce ce tard et cherche à
tout prix à vouzan pringuet dans ce
foutu merdier que ça vous chante ou non
on est d'accord la direction générale de
los angeles et un dossier complet là
dessus tout liège aurait rien d'autre à
vous apprendre je suis désolé mike
excusez moi mc on a relevé des
empreintes à la fois sur l' enveloppe
fedex et sur la photo pardon je vais me
mêler de ce qui ne le regarde pas si
vous traitez les empreintes vous
trouverez sans doute les miennes celles
du livreur celle du manutentionnaire
celle du père noël et de son troupeau de
rennes si ça se trouve mais vous n'en
trouverez aucune du tueur c'est qu'ils
déjanté emprunte à vos ordres
[Musique]
vous êtes encore jeune vous n'avez pas
l'intention de rester un incapacité tout
va très vite
j'avale 200 mg de ces connaît l'histoire
de pouvoir dormir deux heures et demie
par nuit deux fois dans la journée je
m'enfile 100 mg d'assez but de lol avec
20 mg de la danse in pour un problème de
tension
et pour clore le tout chemin jacquetin
antimigraineux chaque fois que le coeur
mendient cocktail c'est pas idéal quand
on doit bosser
vous avez peut-être peur oui c'est
évident
j'ai peur d'accord alors on va en parler
j'arrive quelque part et j'oublie
pourquoi je suis venu je loupe les
sorties de tout et je m'estime heureux
quand je retrouve mon chemin revenant de
chez le traiteur août chez l'épicier là
le plus souvent j'ai oublié le sac avec
les courses dedans même réussissez à
venir ici toutes les semaines deux fois
par semaine
ouais c'est une réalité
imaginez que la prochaine photo qui
arrive sur celle de votre fille
franchement vous apprécieriez qu'on me
charge de l' enquête
je crois que oui
oui
j'apprécierais
[Musique]
salut c'est moi moi
- qui
gel dans cette ville
pourquoi tu a déménagé ici
qu'est ce que tu veux qu est ce que tu
attendes moi tu reste cloîtré dans son
appartement
et quand tu en sors c'est pour aller
dans cette immonde cantine vietnamienne
août udine tous les soirs l'impression
que je tends nuit entre nous je
m'attendais à un accueil plus chaleureux
je n'ai jamais demandé de me suivre dans
l'illinois avec le gars qui t'a
remplacer quand tu es parti j'ai fait en
sorte que ça fonctionne seulement tu
vois ça n'a pas accroché avec lui
j'étais prêt à tout laisser tomber je te
jure et puis je me suis dit chicago se
passait mal
un stylo et du papier justifie les
numéros de téléphone l'enquêteur chargé
de son dossier
ouais tu pourra lui faire part de tes
états d'âme comme ça parce que moi j'en
ai rien à jouer
j'essaie de jeu à l ton boulot est
difficile alors je suis prêt à faire un
geste pour que toi et moi on y trouve
finalement notre quand ils feraient quoi
exactement
les photos aux jo n je vais envoyer une
photo et tu auras une journée pour
trouver la fille fallait j'en dis que
j'aurais mieux fait d'aller dormir dur
c'est du conte
je te souhaite une bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que c'est ça ne répondait pas je
suis venu vous apporter
vous aimez partie a offert
où
merci beaucoup
les photos aux jo elle
je vais t'envoyer une photo
et tu auras une journée pour trouver la
fille jamais vu qu'est ce qui lui est
arrivé elle est morte
à aucun moment je ne vous ai parlé 2006
les fautes on se dit que vous avez
directement celle que l'on imaginé que
la prochaine photo qui arrivent sont
celles de votre fille franchement vous
apprécieriez qu'on ne charge de l'
enquête
je vais t'envoyer une photo et tu auras
une journée pour trouver
j'ai reçu silent demierre je veux cette
enquête
êtes vous sûr d'être en état on sort
assez vite
qu'est ce qui vous a raconté d'autres ce
trou du cul tout est là nous avons
installé une remontée d'appel sur cette
ligne et sans votre portable c'est quoi
ça ça serait pas un oiseau un poster on
dirait que ça a été pris à l'intérieur
elle a pu être fait n'importe où mais
c'est un tirage grand public sont
vérifiées à quoi correspondent ces
chiffres je veux la liste des labos et
des boutiques qui tirent leurs photos
sur cette qualité de papier un portable
c'est le mien climat sera fait excusez
moi je n'ai pas retenu maintenant mills
casper match
faites moi un agrandissement de la photo
qu'on voit ce qu'il ya sur le mur
derrière elle le truc orange et bleu
d'accord lui chercher d'où viennent ces
boucles d'oreilles son pull son tee
shirt
est-ce que la sur son verre de lunette
arrière reflet hockey trouvez moi un
maximum d'infos sur les deux filles
vivait seul
elle avait très peu de relations la
dernière n'avait plus ses parents
n'avaient aucune amis enfin d'après ce
qu'on sait est ce que c'est le profil de
ses victimes
non d'accord les victimes sont toujours
deux jeunes femmes et là ils envoient
des photos il ne s'en prendra donc qu'à
des solitaires des jeunes femmes que
personne ne remarque il n'en verra
jamais la photo d'une reine de beauté
ouais avant de faire quoi que ce soit on
doit prendre une décision pas ton oui ou
non avertir les médias il faut la
prendre tout de suite maintenant il n'y
a pas de décision à prendre
c'est clair que sans les médias on n'y
arrivera pas c'est cet homme qui rate
devant les caméras ils font un carton
tout ce que je peux vous dire pour
l'instant c'est que nous avons de bonnes
raisons de penser que la vie de cette
jeune fille est sérieusement menacé la
police de chicago et le fbi lé
travaillent de concert pour retrouver sa
trace et nous vous remercions par avance
du soutien que vous pourrez nous
apporter dans cette délicate affaire
chaque heure chaque minute est cruciale
ce sera tout
on s en fait les autorités
on l'a retrouvé
c'est chercher d'où viennent ces boucles
d'oreilles son pull à 100 t-shirts de
quoi tu te plains tu attends diana c'est
moi qui mène l enquête libye ouvre la
porte et qui se greffe là-dessus captain
barbituriques
qu'est ce que j'en ai à [ __ ] moi qui
l'ait déjà eu affaire à ce psychopathe
s'il est capable de bosser sans se
déchirer la tête
on peut tout à fait se passer de lui non
non aucune récompense d'aucune sorte
n'est prévue mais je suis sûr qu'on peut
y remédier bien bien vous l'avez vu
aujourd'hui c'était aujourd'hui
non je vous remercie nous allons
vérifier nous
autour de 90 coups de fil en moins de 20
minutes ça fait un bon paquet de
possibles de peut-être on essaye de
faire le tri mais c'est le flou intégral
par tous les moyens à mettre en avant
cet après midi la police n'a toujours
pas retrouvé la jeune fille dont ils ont
reçu la photo ce matin les enquêteurs
comptent toujours sur votre
collaboration pour résoudre cette
terrible affaire
[Musique]
je
metge
c'est quoi ça une lettre envoyée bonjawo
l'agrandir à 300% je peux même vous
l'attirer au maxi on va voir ce que ça
donne sa voix ouais si on n'a pas
l'endroit où la photo a été décrit les
chiffres derrière ne servent à rien bon
mais pour le papier la liste arrive il
paraît que ça concernant 110 en chine
reste quoi vous connaissez le loup
mitchell un restaurant de rocksmith est
du côté de chalco sont georges à lyon
nîmes
oui oui je le reconnais elle avait le
même bandeau dans les cheveux
vous vous souvenez si elle était seul ou
accompagné elle était seule dans la fois
où vous l'avez vu cet accord alors là je
sais par la semaine dernière soyez un
peu plus précisé quel jour exactement
non je risquerais de vous dire une
connerie après bah vous forcez pas
surtout pour rameuter le personnel qui
était de service la semaine dernière je
les veux tout ce restaurant dans une
heure les plongeurs et cuisse tous les
chefs de rang en liga sierre était en
fait vachement du la vie est dure
paiement par carte de toute la semaine
les hommes c'est pas la peine d'un
pareil pour les femmes mariées ou celles
depuis quarante ans les autres faudra
des obscénités
voyez avec bbc peut nous donner un coup
de main pour ça vous avez des gars de
l'hymne des renforts je vais pas
demander qu'on le pouvait leur faxer des
noms parce qu'il va falloir commencer à
contacter les gens on occupe
la police espère qu'à l'heure où des
millions de gens rentrent chez eux et
allument la télévision quelqu'un
reconnaîtra cette jeune femme
les inspecteurs prennent très au sérieux
les menaces qui passionne les murs
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise il est cinq heures six si les gens
sont pas rentrés rappeler plus tard
notre quart d'heure y'a pas rentrer
[Musique]
excusez moi regarder ça
vous aviez raison c'est bien des lettres
arts paix et le trait c'est un point
d'exclamation
ça vous dit quelque chose collé un
ailleurs devant sa ferrari à la fin
c'est râpé wes affaire a fait comme une
des serveuses l'aurait vu ici à peu près
une semaine un regardez bien la photo et
dites moi si vous vous souvenez même
désolé mais moi j'ai un principe les
clients je m'en tape le cul de palets
gâteau je m'en occupe le moins possible
on est là pour s'amuser d'après toi non
alors regarde cette [ __ ] de photos et
dit moi si tu là reconnaît jamais vu
c'est sûr c'est dommage
merci tout nu
[Musique]
j'étais fou renchéri à la télé c'est
joli à super 2000 / de toutes les
chaînes numériques est ce qu'il perd en
but un nom au foot mais au fait les deux
autres sont mortes à quelle heure
9h01 9 heures c'est foutu
on n'y arrivera pas
[Musique]
aperçu trois faux sang commerciaux qui
peuvent y en faut encore sur place vous
voulez venir peut-être elle s'est pas
revu
je vous raconterai
monsieur
écoutez a été aperçu ici à trois
reprises d'accord tous les gens qui se
baladent dans ce centre commercial sont
les témoins potentiels investissez les
lieux je sais pas si elle travaille ici
je sais pas si elle habite le quartier
vous savez ce qu'on sait les lieux photo
call intéressant surtout les gens du
contraire tout le monde
ok tu lequel donc à vous a reçu l'appel
de la dernière personne qui l'a vu c'est
le football
regardez bien la photo quelque chose
avec mon collègue vous plaît regardez la
photo
regardez bien la photo
je
le
à
c'est là qu'on se contredit soir
un salut francky ça a été ta journée
ah oui c'est génial ça moi rien de 300
ans
bonsoir
excusez moi c'est vous qui l'avez vous
tél oui si comme tout ça j'ai vu en
battant paris sans issue là oui là quand
tu après midi il devait plusieurs
ennemis excusez moi
hollis on a une piste
c'est dans ce magasin c'est ici qu'il a
photographié la regarder salud c'est
bien ça et on vous plaît aux connaissez
vous cette fille vient d'être embauché
ici
si annie de son nom de famille et son
téléphone ça urge c'est quoi son numéro
j'attends encore je dois beaucoup et
c'est ça les y avait ici allô maman tu
calmes voyons qu'est ce que tu dis non
je suis sûr que non
mais arrête pour que tu dis ça
écoute maman non attends ça m'étonnerait
fort que ton pharmaciens voight
empoisonné et il a je suis en train de
regarder un film maman pourrait pas voir
ça plus tard
oui maman je suis avec la norme
oui même si c'est sérieux je n'en sais
rien j'ai une idée je te dis comment il
s'appelle et je raccroche
il s'appelle franck oui tu voudras paris
un ebook nervis de c'est urgent non non
s'il vous plaît je vous rappelle que
c'est urgent c'est une question de vie
ou de mort plus mal aux pieds
c'est beaucoup plus drôle comme ça on
vit tous si près les uns des autres mais
personne ne fait plus vraiment attention
à personne
je fais attention à toi
[Musique]
laïb est clair
24 ans célibataire parents installés en
floride
votre petite amie apparemment elle avait
un chat franck et la bestiole n'a pas
regardé les infos je me demande où il
est passé ce chat épluchez les factures
de téléphone
ok agenda journal courier carnaval on
voit s'il était en relation avec les
victimes
[Musique]
madame vous n'auriez pas une petite
pièce des pièces
ça lui va pas
mais papa tu me reconnais pas c'est moi
et messieurs vous n'auriez pas une
petite pièce qu'est ce que tu fais là
toi quoi ça soit non je fais la manche
pourquoi tu n'as pas de travail tu me
files du blé ou pas seulement si tu
danses avec moi ça va là chemin chez
sérieux ya pas de musique je mène tu
n'as qu'à suivre et 1 2 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
saloperie de sourds avec talent humain
avec des nommés voilà peut-être qu'avec
leur pic j'arrive rattraper coloris que
ses baguettes tient toujours
je veux plus ce machin chat colonna bon
en fait noble qu'est ce que tu as
d'intéressant sur cette petite sirène au
sourire ravageur tue c'est l'agent
fédéral comment s'appelle la caisse que
donnerait pas en laissant le petit quart
d'heure avec elle sur une aire
d'autoroute une grand plâtre et chimie
non j'ai pas vrai déjà dégoté la garde
jack prend bien soin sur l'autre soir
griffin aussi m'a pris la tête avec ça
au téléphone jusqu'à ce cas
ça se trouve il est en train de nous
observer en ce moment même
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît restez
pas là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me trouve actuellement devant
l'immeuble de annie peau claire la jeune
femme que les gens de chicago connaît
sous le nom de jane x les recherches de
20 minutes nous ont terminé tragiquement
soit à 9h20 quand la police a découvert
le corps d'un ebook nerfs dans son
appartement de wick marque
les habitants de ce quartier paisible
sont sous le choc à mes côtés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ja
et se porte comme un chat
excusez moi
[Musique]
je ne vais pas rester longtemps je
voulais voulez vous voir et vous dire
combien j'ai apprécié notre enfin ce que
parce que vous avez dit l'autre jour où
en êtes vous avec la migraine presque au
même point est-ce que vous dormez oui un
peu
le travail super je commence à avoir un
véritable fan club à la criminelle qui
ressentait vous on passera sa pensée à
cet homme qui vous est suivie jusque
dans l'illinois
est ce une vengeance c'est une drôle de
question je trouve non non je crois que
la vengeance n'a rien à voir avec ça
c'est un scénario bien rodé il obéit à
une sorte de rituel et avec le temps il
a fait de moi le personnage central
probablement que sans moi l'histoire ne
fonctionnait pas en d'autres termes
voulu manquer à los angeles
c'est curieux et lui ils vont manquer ça
voudrait dire quoi selon vous
excusez-moi gamble c'est ben jarry
[Musique]
bouët 1,6
c'est devenir quelqu'un de la mairie et
pourront peut-être nous en dire plus sur
ce bout de trottoir
vérifiez tout voyez ici c'est le métro
aérien et parcmètres aussi les appliquer
mitch sa photo dans tous les salons de
tatouage sol
[Musique]
comment tu t'appelles
et bien aujourd'hui monsieur abraham
nous allons avoir ce que j'appellerais
un entretien préliminaire afin de mieux
cerner ce que vous attendez de cette
thérapie
si vous et moi sans temps je suis la
personne qui vous convient leblanc alors
décidé du jour et de l'heure des séances
jeu j'aime bien enregistrer les séances
mais si vous souhaitez vous vous servez
d'un magnétophone avec tous vos patients
10 ans avec la majorité mais j'aime je
peux aussi ne pas le faire oui je
préférerais d'accord
de toute façon c'est vous qui décidez
quels domaines cela concerne-t-il
lorsque vous dites que vous pourriez
avoir besoin dead sait pas trop encore
quel genre bug portez vous et bien tout
dépend du patient je travaille sur
différents qu'un pensez vous
est il possible que certains de vos
patients le viennent vous voir que parce
que vous êtes jolie s'il vous plaît
essayez de nous concentrer sur vous
plutôt que sur moi mes yeux bruns
[Musique]
d'accord
derrière on est une partie commencée
techniques vous faîtes presse avec m il
ya deux ans ils ont procédé à la
réhabilitation de ce quartier ils ont
mis des bornes autour de quelques arbres
c'est dans le centre-ville où ça dans le
centre ville tu me sortir le plan digues
ils ont entre broadway et belmont ça
concerne une vingtaine de rues sinon
plus
5 millions d'habitants dans cette ville
nous dépeint peu d'argent j'ai fait
pareil avec moi papa je suis assis
de chicago et si on dit la police
recherche toujours la jeune femme que
l'on voit sur la photographie qui leur a
été adressée
les menaces de meurtre pourrait provenir
d'un tueur en série qui jusqu'ici a sévi
dans la région de los angeles
à l'heure où je vous parle la jeune
femme que les policiers appellent
deviennent x2 n'a pas encore été
localisée et les membres de l'équipe
chargée de cette affaire ne cachent pas
leur inquiétude
[Musique]
allô c'est bon j'arrive
diffusion de sa photo sur les pistes de
skate board et dans les magasins de
musique enfin entre broadway belle monde
sait ça si je pouvais trouver des
lettres venant trouverez pas elle
n'écrit vais jamais à personne elle n'a
téléphoné que trois fois depuis qu'il
est parti
elle vous a peut-être dit d'où elle
appelait elle a dit tellement de choses
difficile de faire le tri entre les
vrais il faut et la nouveauté qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire sur lui il est
avocat et ouais qu'est ce qu'elle a pu
vous dire d'autre qui pourrait nous
aider essayer de vous rappeler il y a
trois mois nous a téléphoné pour nous
annoncer qu'elle travaillait au seattle
baisse café seattle's best ne sont pas
terribles ne travaille pas et elle n'a
jamais travaillé aussi à trausse peste
police qu'elle travaille pas au seattle
c'est secondaire elle est assise devant
un coffee shop
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise je
vais sur un banc ça peut être n'importe
où je peux raconter des histoires
regardez bien la photo sont sept
normalement debout ou assis trois de ces
personnes tiennent le même gobelet de
café
elle est assise devant un coffee shop
envoie une équipe faire la tournée de
tous les siècles baisse de la ville
et de toutes les buvettes qui sert du
café entre broadway événement hockey
[Musique]
d'accord tu veux me tuer allais-je
parles tu veux si belle remontée sur toi
et jessica szohr vous les afficher
bonsoir madame leurs recherches sur
cette jeune fille
sûr et certain alpha chez nous
régulièrement un jeune qui la connaît
aussi à sospel sur lincoln des mousses
comme jean bienvenu déjà il faut que j'y
aille
ces badges je sais mais je suis en
retard je pourrais entrer en douce dans
ta chambre non la dernière fois qu'on
s'est fait pincer mon père à disjoncter
c'est que partie remise c'est l'habitude
[Musique]
elle est réglo alors je lui interdis
parallaxe à l'antenne d'ailleurs j'ai
dit aux autres qui j'en ai rien à
secouer de ce que tu as dit aux autres
je veux savoir où elle habite je veux
savoir où il est dans la rue
[Musique]
de vous la retrouvez ce soir appelez moi
ce numéro si vous voyez cette jeune
fille aidez nous à retrouver cette jeune
fille madame en a deux autres très
regardé cette affiche
contactée la police si vous rien céder
au dessus des bougies mais aidez vous
sans vous on peut rien demain une sans
trop tard et doit retrousser terry
jamais il n'a croisé avec ce numéro
et pourtant tu regardes cette [ __ ] de
photoquai regarde la photo table s'est
fait quelques pas un an
excusez moi mais buysse est finie
regardez la photo à rendre compte avez
vous vu cette fille comme ça excusez moi
j'avais voulu cette fille non ça me
revient
le visage vous dit quelque chose non et
comme monsieur et vous avez vu cette
fille tu avais vu cette fille soit a dit
le contraire regarde cette connaît cette
fille elle a à peu près tout je sais
rien moi je t'emmerde
salut salut
très sympa à ce titre wii
je trouve cool
hyper cool
et
je monte le son paquet
timika
[Musique]
sais tu me dis pas rouler moins d'une
heure ton amie jessica sera morte
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on veut monter les étages
tu
ce qui te plaît
[Musique]
à
où ça normalement l'état ou au lycée
[Musique]
bon
en
[Musique]
bah
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
kambol kambol ça va ouvrez
ouvrez là
quand mal fait a répondu
[Musique]
il est gelé mitch une ambulance
ce matin les enquêteurs recherchent
toujours le tueur en série responsable
du dra-10 reçoit trois policiers ont été
brûlés vifs et une jeune fille a été
assassinée
l'agent du fbi a dirigé les opérations à
lui été hospitalisé
bonjour l'entraidé
nous y oblige et je sais mais comment
vous seriez venu chez moi donc je suis
là et puis les temps sont durs je tiens
à conserver des patients que j'ai ils
sont rares alors je ne veux pas risquer
de louper un jeu mois
c'est à dire qu'en dehors du cabinet
vous êtes très différentes
en revanche vous je dois dire que vous
êtes tout à fait
si heureux
vous avez déjeuné
il faut manger ils ont donné une loge
les vitamines et ça vous dirait le
goûter allez courage
essayons
[Musique]
en d'autres termes pour les mots qui
vous intéressent
entre-temps voulu monter à los angeles
selon lui le monde
non non j'ai pas le temps désolé je
serai peut-être excusez moi j'en casper
c'est un courrier pour la gent gand
belgique
comment est l'état du chemin lapostolle
a fait suivre vu qu'en ce moment il est
absent merci bonjour et merci encore de
votre attention
mon intervention sera on ne peut plus
brève
comme beaucoup d'entre vous le savent
déjà nous avons reçu une nouvelle photo
en fin de matinée non n'insistez pas
aujourd'hui je ne répondrai à aucune
question suilhard un seul et unique but
vous confier la photo et vous demander
de continuer à nous aider dans nos
recherches
ce sera tout merci l'inspecteur holisme
à qui confirme donc le jeu macabre du
chat de la souris se poursuit voici la
photo de la dernière cible du tueur
''j'ai mx3
[Musique]
tu n'arrives d'usure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça sert confiance en toute amitié
[Musique]
salut joe n est ton coeur comment il va
la soif une bière après tu te sentiras
mieux
n'avance pas
j'aimerais savoir c'est pour être plus
près d'elle que tu a déménagé à 3000 km
c'est ça avoue mahdi dont la falloir que
tu sortes un peu plus c'est vrai c'est
une relation épanouissante franchement
elle même un peu elle se décompose elle
m'aime beaucoup elle se décompose je
peux savoir ce qu'on fait là à quoi tu
joues tu as l'intention de te rendre
peut-être pourquoi tu as caché à tout le
monde que tu l'as sauter parce qu'elle
était mariée
la communication passe plus très bien
entre nous je vais devoir clarifier les
choses je n'hésiterai pas une seule
seconde de décembre là où tu es à je
réfléchirai quand même à ta place
si je meurs ton ami paul y risquent fort
de connaître un sort épouvantable avec
deux jolis flammes
sans oublier la grande mare de kérosène
si on connaît un rayon toi sur les
jeunes femmes carbonisés raconte moi
c'était comme angel tu as vraiment senti
l'odeur de sa chair brûlée
tu l'as déjà tué
je t'en prie duel tu me connais mieux
que sa leçon sur la carte s'était même
pas le tien an men - la voir dans ce cas
très sincèrement j'hésite je préférerais
qu'on reste un peu ici à discuter je la
vois et ensuite en discuter
il faut que je sois sûr que ça vaille le
coup de discuter se comprend
un vase il prend le d'abord je vérifie
qu'elle a rien et ensuite on discute
très bien
aussi
je suis heureux de te voir très heureux
merde et les charger
on va aller jusqu'au bout cette fois ci
pas vrai duel
je crois que ça dépend plus de toi de
moi j'ai pris un coup de vieux depuis
los angeles
tu es un ami fidèle
tu es comme un frère pour moi tu ne sais
ça tu as de vrais frères et soeurs quoi
si jaloux mais c'est quoi ce délire on a
une conversation normale et tout ce que
tu trouves à faire c'est jouer les psy
attends tu te prends pour le docteur
paul tout d'un coup je voulais juste
savoir ces trois cartes de moi quand je
te parle d'accord tu cherche à contrôler
la situation ne cherche pas à contrôler
la situation
je ne peux pas oublier ton boulot pour
une fois tu veux que je te dise je
trouve que tu passes un peu trop de
temps avec cette [ __ ] de psy de quoi tu
as besoin pense à ceux dont tu as besoin
ok je te propose un deal je te donne ce
que tu veux et en échange d'une tente
rien contre madame bellman ça va j'ai
besoin de toi
là
allo
à bientôt
l'enfoiré de mes deux chiens campbell
localiser le tue le seul à avoir pensé à
moi tu me connais vraiment
pendant longtemps rappelle toi
tu ne lui que moi joy
et puis tu as rencontré dix à vingt six
gars toi là
[Musique]
une seconde nommée au nord de la ville
ouais mais va falloir être plus précis
allait aller en allemagne fait pas chier
tu me lâches une minute je te donne
l'endroit exact où lisandro chacun sayad
jeune kyle est au bord de l'eau
nous
à
tu peux entrer
pauli john dalli pauli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
mais
ce pas
[Musique]
ja
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on se réveille de rennes ça fait mal
j'en suis sûr les flashs la migraine ne
font pas bon ménage d'après ce qu'on
racontait t même pas drôle
oh non poli non non je ne vais pas tuer
votre ami on a besoin l'un de l'autre
on se complète on est le yin et le yang
blanc et noirs c'est pas vrai poli
pauli
j'ai dit c'est pas vrai
je ne comprends pas votre question la
grande professionnelle que vous êtes
dirait tels que joe elle et moi avons
besoin l'un de l'autre pour donner un
sens à notre vie
tu vois
[Musique]
la touche pas nenê est la touche pas tu
entends assieds-toi jo elle
si toi
si tu veux restaurer ainsi toute la nuit
sur cette chaise à t'écouter allez fais
pas le con on est d'accord la shna à
l'epo ce conflit non c'est toi et moi
que tu ne vas pas t'en servir et pour qu
on le sait ça parce que ça ne colle pas
avec ta mise en scène il a raison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
debout debout
comment tu trouves ça ne te rappelle
rien nous avons le feu
la jolie femme terrorisée ce qui aurait
dû nous rapprocher nous a séparés
tu es parti à chicago tu devais te
sentir sacrément coupable pour te tirer
ou bien quelque chose dans ce goût là
j'essaie tu veut m'entendre dire c'est
vrai je me sens coupable oui parce que
mon erreur a coûté la vie à lisa non non
non c'était pas ça l'erreur non l'erreur
c'est de m'avoir tourner le dos au lieu
de s'investir à fond dans notre relation
alors je veux je veux que tu me disent
merci tu aurais je veux que tu me disent
merci d'avoir fait le voyage jusqu'ici
pour sauver sa triste vie
david tu sais combien de tueurs en série
sont en activité à chicago aujourd'hui 5
dans tout le midwest
ils doivent être une douzaine je peux
changer d'affaires sans même avoir à
boucler mes valises tués renversés par
un bus jeudi le pastel eu lundi un
nouveau client pour moi tu n'es qu'un
travail un bout de paperasse
bah
incroyable tu n'as toujours pas compris
à qui tu t'adresses je suis homme et il
ne comprend que cela engage à vous l'ait
entendu ça passe merci qu'est ce que tu
disais tu dis merci je n'ai pas bien
entendu je dis merci
[Musique]
obama
à
[Musique]
il
et parce que la couverture et
fille va bien ouais
chez vous de repêcher le corps va faire
le nécessaire
[Musique]
jamais si facile quand on débarque et
nous attendent rarement assis sur une
chaise sourire accueillant au coin des
lèvres
on croise les doigts pour qu'ils
finissent par faire une connerie et pour
être là le jour béni où ça arrive
[Musique]
terminé pour aujourd'hui